good afternoon members and officers can
i welcome you to this planning committee
meeting on the
18th of november uh
as always i think we're all getting used
to this now um
a roll call if i may see who's with us
um i almost think we nearly have full
attendance this afternoon but as always
if you could
say you're here when i go through your
names please uh
council robin yeah here chair cancer
bayfoods
here chad councillor coleman cook
purcha camper curry
here chair counselor dennis
i know he's not counselor duckworth
councilman ghana i'm here
dancer heart
counselor keane here chair
council more
sorry that's on my list still
pat moore is not with us now obviously
uh norway's councillor zesky council
scott
counselor taylor
councillor right here
and obviously i am and office
is with us um mr livingston
uh i see annabelle i'm not sure about
emma today
um no it's it's it's
just myself and annabelle today chair
thank you ian
um suki um
our office the democratic uh and
james right thank you very much members
um i think we all again know this off by
heart now but it's a part of the role to
play
if you have any technical difficulties
during the meeting
then please contact the democratic
services officer on call
who will attempt to assist you uh that
is james this afternoon
and his number is five double seven two
zero
zero uh
if you have any problems um please uh
get in touch with him his name
and the number should be up there thank
you james it is
uh i also would ask um
that if you have a your microphone
please on mute
uh this saves any noise in the
background that can be picked up
and help everybody else who is listening
to the proceedings
microphones must only be on if this
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain permission to speak please very
briefly indicate in the chat box on your
right hand side of the screen
i will then note and come back to you
once the person speaking
has finished and as i've said members
before i do see your names come up and i
make a note
if i have missed you please
indicate and shout at me but everybody
present please ensure their mobile
phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls once
the meeting is in progress please also
refrain from checking emails or
conducting other business
and ensure that you are in a quiet room
free from distractions
for the duration of the meeting
please note that this meeting is being
live streamed
for members of the public and the
following meeting
will then be available on the council's
youtube channel once we finish
uh i don't have any members um
which who aren't on the committee under
20.1
to speak this afternoon if there are
could they please indicate
is silence
thank you very much so we have no
members speaking under 20.1
um agenda item one apologies for
absence now i've got apologies for
council ruth duckworth on here but
you're there ruth
um i don't know why that is but i do
have apologies for
uh councillor dennis
are there any other apologies
no agenda item two
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest
thank you uh proving the minutes
of the meeting held on the 21st of
october
2020 were approved at the previous
meeting
there are no other minutes to be
approved at
this time agenda item three
scheduler planning applications and
public speaking
game months gain members site visits
even more so um can't happen
at this stage uh because of covid
and i think we're all longing for things
to get back to normal
the following applications have been
reserved for public speaking
and that is agenda item 3
b so moving on to
agenda item 3b it's planning an
application
to defer and delegate number two
cliffview road ramsgate i would ask
um our officer tsuki please to read out
a statement
uh from the member from a person who is
in favor of this application
thank you thank you chair
this is a statement good evening members
my name is alistair hume of hume
planning consultancy
and i'm speaking in support of this
application at two cliff view road
the proposals are for the redevelopment
of the existing bungalow to create two
semi-detached three-bedroom dwellings i
believe it is generally accepted
that the current dwelling to be replaced
is of a poor design and substandard
internal layout
which is dilapidated and makes no
positive contribution to the street
scene
the proposal i believe will improve the
look of the building whilst
making more efficient use of a
brownfield site within the settlement of
cliff's end
where development is both supported and
encouraged by local and national
planning policy
it is also relevant that we feel that
following a reduction in scale
the living conditions of adjoining
occupiers will also be safeguarded
your officers also concur with this
conclusion
throughout the course of the application
the applicant has worked with the case
officer to take account of their
feedback
and the comments of neighbours which has
resulted in significant amendments to
the massing of the new building of the
new dwellings
including the front gable element has
been reduced to single story
so that the main ridge height has been
lowered by 1.2 meters
compared to that originally proposed the
built form has been pulled off
the side boundaries by over two meters
on both sides
which is more than double the distance
that was originally proposed
the depth of the building footprint has
been reduced by
1.5 meters to provide a back-to-back
separation distance of over 30 meters
with number four folds hill to the rear
a total of three neighbor comments have
been received on the application
two comments neither objected nor
supported the application but
raised concerns over the massing of the
development under the originally
consulted scheme
which has now been reduced as explained
earlier as well as the impact of the new
driveway
on a telegraph poll located outside of
the site
on the public footwear which will remain
unaffected as a result of the proposals
one objection has been received from the
neighbour on the opposite side of the
road
mentioning impact on daylight levels
received
and pollution levels from increased car
traffic
given the distance of separation and the
minor nature of the proposal
being a net gain of one dwelling and the
fact that
environmental health have not raised any
concerns
the application is considered to be
acceptable in these aspects
given that one the proposal will replace
the existing dilapidated dwelling and
will improve the appearance of the
street scene
two the principle of development is
supported by the development plan
and mppf three the proposal is supported
by the case officer
and no objections have been reset raised
by the statutory council teams and
full the development will be constructed
to a high standard of energy and water
efficiency
to be secured by conditions eight and
nine
it is respectfully requested that
members grant permission for this
application
in line with the officer's
recommendation
thank you very much i also just like to
make a note that um councillor taylor
and
scott are now with us on the committee
uh
thank you both uh for letting me know
i will ask the planning officer now to
outline the report please
i believe that is annabelle
yes it is chair i'll just annabelle
hopefully members can see my screen now
yeah
sorry um this is the application site
outlined in red
with canterbury road west sorry running
along the top of the
slide here and cliff view road running
down here
and folds hill um on the right hand side
so some aerial views of the application
site in the surrounding area the
application site is here number two
this is cliff house to the north and
number four
um clifford cliff view road to the south
another view of the application site
which is here
and so
sorry bear with me um this is looking
the other way of the application site
this is the rear garden of the site
and the house that's currently sits on
the site there
and again another view of the
application site which is here
um some photographs of the application
site so this is number two
um cliff view road this is cliff house
and we can see the garden of um
number two sloping down away from
canterbury road west
and this is the the side garden of
number two
and this is number four cliff view road
and this is a general sort of street
view of cliff view road
so this is the application site here
number four cliff view road
and cliff house um sitting
next to number two um just some
photographs going into the site
so this is number two on the right-hand
side cliff house
and we're going down obviously between
the two properties here
this is the rear um of the site the
application
site um
and we're moving across now enough of
you of the rear of the site and the
boundary with number four
um this is the boundary with number four
this fence you can see here
the application site the
existing property on the application
site here
this is the again looking back at the
existing property on the application
site and you can see the relationship
between it and
number sorry cliff house um
joining it and this again is looking
from the applications
rear of the application site to the
existing bungalow
we have number four cliff view road
on the left and cliff house on the right
sorry excuse me this is the existing um
block plan so this is the bungalow here
it has a garage
um here the side garden we saw in the
photographs and the rear garden
wrapping around
so this is the proposed block plan so
you'd have
two um a pair of semi-detached shallow
bungalows sitting on the site as
proposed
they'd have amenity space to the front
and to the rear and would each be served
by a single
parking space so i'll just take you
through some elevations of the existing
bungalow so this is the front
and this is the proposed front elevation
of
the new properties proposed so
they'd be symmetrical they'd have a
gable feature
facing onto the front and then you can
see the two parking spaces that would be
proposed to serve them
this existing rear elevation of the
bungalow that we've just seen in the
photographs and this is the proposed
rear elevation
and we have the north side elevation of
the existing which faces cliff
um house and this is the south elevation
that would
currently face is number four and we
have
the proposed side elevations so this
would be the side elevation fronting
um cliff house and this will be facing
number four
and i don't know if members can see but
the um
notation for the windows within the
dormer
is actually to be obscure glaze and when
we look at the floor plans
you'll you'll see they serve a bathroom
so this is the ground floor of the
property as existing
and this is the ground floor the
proposed um
units and the front of the units is
actually to the top of the slide
so you see they actually have a bedroom
on the ground floor as well as
living accommodation kitchen open plan
living space and study areas
and this is the first floor these are
the dormers that we've seen on the side
so they're obscure glaze and as i say
serve bathrooms
and each property would have a further
two bedrooms
um we have the street sceners existing
so you can see the slope where it
goes down from canterbury road west this
is cliff
house the existing bungalow
and number four and the street scene has
proposed
um on the bottom here again cliff house
and we have um the two proposed
um chalet bungalows
they would be slightly taller than the
existing
property that's on the site but they
have been reduced
and brought in from the sides as well
following members concerns about the
impact and scale
of the proposed weddings when it
initially when they initially came in
so again looking at the um
the block plan of the site has proposed
it is considered
whilst there aren't many semi-detached
properties in this part of cliffview
road
the scale of the dwellings are not out
of proportion with other dwellings
within the street scene
or the scale of other plots so we do not
consider there would be an adverse
impact on the character and appearance
excuse me of the surrounding area they
would be served by
a parking space each and there is
unrestricted parking
on road parking along cliff road cliff
view road and other surrounding roads
they would each have
an area of amenity space um
so it is considered on the whole that
they would provide a good standard of
accommodation for
future residents um subsequent to
um the amendments that have been made
it is considered there wouldn't be any
impact on the residential amenity
of surrounding occupiers from the
proposed development
um again it's highlighted the windows
here
and on the avodorma would be obscure
glazed and there is
approximately 30 meters between the two
properties
proposed and number four to the rear
there has been an undertaking
submitted subsequently to the agenda
being published which does um
secure the um required
sam contribution but this has not been
reviewed in full
so the recommendation before members is
still to defer
and delegated so that review of the
undertaking can be formally
submitted thank you chair
uh thank you annabelle i move that the
officer's recommendation is adopted
could the vice chair please
second oh second nature uh thank you
councillor coleman cook
um members it's over to you um
i have some names already councillor
alban
yeah thank you chair thank you annabelle
for the presentation
um could you just advise me uh
what is the how much wider
is this development than the existing
bungalow please
are you okay to do i don't i have the
exact
measurements in terms of wideness of it
um but bear with me no i don't
unfortunately
but it the proposed
if i the proposed dwelling did sit
closer to
um well probably in the same position
with the garage
attached to the north with cliff um
house to the north
but there was obviously a larger um
side garden and gap between
the southern boundary and number four
so what we're talking about uh three
meters
saying of that nature it would probably
be about
approximately that yes okay thank you
thank you carl allman um councillor
keane
yeah thank you and just two questions
the first one is there going to be any
trees lost because i did notice some
trees in the original pictures so are
they
staying and the second was just there
was some kind of structure in the garden
is that staying as well or was that just
where they're living with their caravan
at the moment
um in terms of the structures i
understand they
are to be demolished and my caravan was
only there
it's a touring caravan i think it was
just parked on site and
you wouldn't generally it's not being
lived in you know
okay it's just a touring caravan that
the bungalow have um in terms of trees i
do understand that the trees
are to be lost but they are not
protected
by virtue of a tree preservation order
or
by virtue of being in a conservation
area i think the one
the larger tree that we saw sort of sits
sat
just to the rear of where the proposed
dwelling would go um between so i think
that would have to be lost as part of
the development but
but it is not protected yeah okay thank
you
uh thank you councillor ghana yeah thank
you yeah
um councillor keane sort of hinted at
what i wanted to ask about as well
obviously i understand yeah the trees
aren't protected so
there's nothing much that can be done
about that my my disappointment
with looking at the pictures of what the
what it's going to look like it seems
another new
development of houses with a lot of
concrete involved
and not a lot of green i can see there's
a nice
lawn out the back but it's again it's a
lot of hard standing
and is there any sort of landscaping
plan or commitment from the developer
who's going to do this
about um what that green is going to be
annabelle can you answer that yes chess
sorry just turning the microphone on
um well normally we wouldn't excuse me a
request a landscaping scheme for a
development of this size
but there is as shown in the block plan
and these are the plans we'll be
approving
um a garden area to the front of the
development as well as the garden area
to the rear we wouldn't normally dictate
obviously what they
plant within a private garden but it is
anticipated that those
green areas or garden areas would be
come forward as
as part of the development
thank you you happy that council garner
yeah i just uh i just have a general
problem i think with a lot of these new
houses
being built that just seem to have so
much concrete out the front
and quite a lot out the back as well but
no fair comment thank you very much
uh i don't see any other members wishing
to speak on this application
so um i'm now going to put
this to you which is the officer's
recommendation
to defer and delegate and i think
members you know how this works once
again
um if you fought if you're for the
motion
please say four or if you're against
against
or going to abstain so once again the
roll call
um starting with councillor coleman cook
for
councilwoman for councillor bayford
four councillor curry four
councilman perth four
councilman ghana against
councillor hart four councillor keane
myself i'm for it as well
that's virtually unanimous
and carried i will get confirmation
um from james i'm sure
or from me yes it is thank you very much
uh thank you james i know i can add up
but
i'd like to get it confirmed by yourself
uh thank you members um well that
concludes uh public speaking for this
meeting
i will call upon the clerk to read out
the remaining planning
application if a member wishes to
reserve
this application will they please call
out
as she reads i think it's over to katie
i believe
what yeah the only remaining item
is a gender item 3a that's 13
linden avenue broadstairs kent ct 10
1 hr thank you very much
sorry yes please counselor ghana
yeah i know i think council bayford was
as well
yes i did i couldn't get the mic i
haven't got
rydo members um
right this is down for obviously for
approval
um and i'm not sure who's doing this
presentation
is it yourself again it's annabelle
annabelle again you're doing well this
afternoon annabelle so i'm going to hand
over to you
i'll just present the screen
um hopefully members can see the screen
so this is the application site outlined
in red it may be familiar to some
members because
it did come before members in a slightly
different form
i mean earlier this year i think it was
may of this year
so we this is number 13 the existing
party
and we have linden avenue wrapping
around here and this is crow hill
so this is the application site in the
middle of the screen here
and number 13 which is the existing
property
and enough of you looking from crow hill
this is number 13 and the application
site sits here
and this is from linden avenue number 13
runs across there and this is the
application site
and so we have enough of you again from
linden avenue this number 13 and the
wider application
site and so i'll take you
show you some quick photos of the site
and the surrounding area
these photos are actually from may 20
uh 20 so i will show you these and i
will show you a couple of more
up-to-date ones at the end
so this is in linden avenue looking at
number 13.
and this is number 13 on the left
and number 15 a adjacent to it
um this is the end of number 13's wall
and we have number 11 linden avenue here
now we've moved to crow hill and this is
the application site here
the roof of number 13 and this is number
28 crow hill and number 30 crow hill
um again this is number 30 crow hill and
the application site here
and this is actually on the application
site and this is number 13.
um this is within again the application
site
and we have this is number 28 number 26
crow hill
these are the more up-to-date
photographs in fact they're actually
taken today
um so this is actually showing that the
site is currently
being worked on and obviously they do
have the benefit of the extant uh
consent from
may and this is again a view
this is again a current photo from today
and this is a from crow hill
excuse me so this was the site layout
we've seen with number 13
here linden avenue and crow hill running
down here
um this is the proposed site layout that
we're considering today
so we have plots number one and two
facing linden avenue and plot three
facing crow hill
um number plot one is actually
number 13 which is to be altered but the
existing property
and plots two and three are brand new
but as has been explained
and this already an extent consent for
the free dwellings
um on the site and that's what we've
seen being
already built out so again this was the
existing property that
is to be alt is being altered and this
is plot two and plot three
so you can see the layout is pretty much
what
we're also considering today it hasn't
changed
um much in terms of the actual layout
and i'll just quickly take you through
some plans with the existing front
elevation of number 13
and the rear elevation of number 13
and the two side elevations of number 13
as they originally stood
um this is the ground floor of number 13
as it stood
and its roof plan um this is plot one
and as i say plot one is number 13 being
altered
so this is the front elevation which
would face lyndon avenue
um the rear elevation and the two side
elevations
so bear with me two seconds
in terms of plot one
the only real difference
other than minor design changes
is that the roof height has increased by
0.1 meters
um against the approved scheme
from may 2020 so
this is the ground floor of the propel
of the property that's being built out
essentially now
and this is the first floor um again the
number of bedrooms remain the same
as the original consent for in in may of
this year
and this is a roof plan excuse me a plot
one
moving on to plot two this is the front
elevation again it faces linden avenue
the rear elevation and the two side
elevations
and in terms of this plot
it the floor area has it been increased
for by 13 square meters
and this increase in size extends the
kitchen living area
and it has been also extended the
southern side
of the ground floor level by two meters
so this is the ground floor of it of the
property is now being proposed
and as we've heard there is that slight
increase
um in the footprint and we also have
the first floor again the bedroom
numbers remain the same between
what's now being proposed and what was
approved in 2012 um
may of this year and we have the roof
planner plot too
um this is the front elevation of plot
three and this is the one that faces
crow hill
um the rear elevation
and the two side elevations and in terms
of
this one there is no change in the
overall height between
that granted in may of this year but the
side projection has increased in height
by 0.6 meters
and there is a very small increase in
the foot overall footprint
by approximately 1.7 square meters
and so we see the ground floor of this
property not plot-free
and its first floor and its roof plan
so this is um the block plan
that we're now considering again
as say the properties are essentially in
the same position
they have minor alterations too and
slight extensions in some instances
they retain their garden areas as
proposed
and they also have parking spaces
um propose officers consider that the
alterations are acceptable and they
don't have
a significant impact on the character
and appearance beyond
that of the area beyond that which was
approved in 2020
or on the living conditions of
neighbouring properties
and again there would be no adverse
impact in terms of highways because no
additional bedrooms or
a significant increase in habitable
space for any property is being created
by this
um amended proposal and in this
instance we do not have an undertaking
for the sam
contribution because the sam
contribution has already been paid
on the original application so it is
considered that that mitigation
mitigation for the recreational pressure
excuse me has already been secured
so in in this instance the officer
recommendation is
for a straight approval of the proposal
thank you chair uh thank you annabelle
i move the officer's recommendation is
adopted i'm pleased with the vice chair
second or second nature uh
thank you and it's uh two members once
again um
let's start here may with councillor
heart
thank you i remember was coming to the
community actually and i think
quite a few of us were concerned about
the overall um
over development of this site um if that
was my
general recollection of this one um and
yes it comes to us again because i want
to increase the footprint
which makes it even a greater footprint
than it was before and even less
recreational space so i'm slightly
perturbed by this that
somebody could play a planning
application and just increase the stones
of property
and still travel rovers um i just i just
feel that
a lot of us i think from recollection
objected to this in the first place
it was just too big and now they're
getting bigger i'm not happy with it to
be fair
okay thank you councillor heart
councillor ghana
yeah thank you i mean i i echo what
council of heart has said we i mean in
my view
that there are three three houses being
crammed into this space
um losing quite a lot of uh green area
that was part of obviously the original
house more concreting over
of um of driveways again
um and i don't and i just think they're
they've gone too far
so i i can't support this
uh thank you council bathroom
council bayford
right sorry um thank you chair um
i concur with everything that counselor
heart and counselor don't garner have
said
um when this development was approved in
may it was against the backdrop of
overwhelming local objection
despite the claim that the new proposed
developments are minor
they will result in some increase to the
bulk and scale
of of the buildings it seems that
residents find it hard to accept that
within six months of being granted
permission to build
the developer is proposing an even
bigger development on what's all
already an extremely cramped site so for
those reasons i'm only unable to
support this application
yeah thank you chair just a question
please uh to annabelle
um why do you know why
the developers have decided to
after they started building to increase
the size and um i wouldn't exactly say
an increase in two meters on plot two
is a is a slight increase
i think it's quite a large increase so
um
can you just advise why that they're
that they're undertaking this now
um no i can't it's obviously coming
i don't know the background as to why i
wish to do it
i understand it may be a new owner who's
maybe slightly differently
can i come back chair please certainly
councilwoman yeah um
i mean in that case chair uh you know
obviously
the principal development is there uh
they've got the consent they've got an
extent consent that
that they can build so i
i i'm going along with the rest of my uh
council colleagues here i just think uh
as i say it is it is a step too far
thank you chair
uh thank you uh council taylor yes
following
on from what council album said really
um annabelle is it possible to see
how the plans were before on plot two
because obviously you said that it's
taken up no garden space
or and how it how it is supposed to be
now
yeah i'll go back to the can you do that
just take a moment sorry
so this is the layout we're considering
today and obviously plot 2
is there um and this was the layout that
was previously approved
can i stop you there annabelle we're not
on screen
sorry bear with me
push the buttons sorry forgot about that
so hopefully members can see it so this
um
the app is the layout that was approved
on the previous
application so i think it was
particularly plot two that was made
reference to us
so that how it looked um on the
previous application that's been
approved
uh sorry i'm on the wrong
going the wrong way now and so this is
the application that you're
looking to consider today
thank you uh councillor taylor do you
wish to come back
i think uh most things have been said
actually i'm not happy you're happy with
this
application okay uh council robin now
you wish to
come back on this yeah i just wanted to
make a point here and that is that
as far as plot one is concerned i don't
consider that to be
a problem what's whatsoever 0.6 increase
in the height is nothing
um it is mainly plot 2
and partly plot 3 which is the which are
the issues chair
i think thank you okay thank you
um now i don't see any other speakers
um so once again members i'm going to
put this
uh to yourselves um
move the motion of the officer
recommendation is
to approve uh i thank you again you know
how this works now
um if i go through your names if you're
for
against or abstain please say so
uh councillor coleman cook
council common cook sorry
we've been totally uh blank there to
chair
i'm i'm against thank you council robin
uh against councillor bayford
against councillor curry against
council duckworth council of ghana
against councilman hart against jerry
keane against council raskin
again council scott
against chair councilman taylor against
chair
council right against and i'm against as
well
um though that has
fallen um so uh
can i come back on this one to
mr livingston i presume
yes uh absolutely um so the
members have outlined the concerns again
about the the increase from the previous
approval and and i think members have
articulated very clearly that
effectively the previous permission was
almost considered the maximum
that the development site could provide
without impacting
on the character appearance of the area
uh to a significant detriment um
um and therefore i i think if if members
were to
to move a uh
effectively that the proposed
development um and i think it's by
virtue it's
the the design and scale uh of the
proposed dwellings of plots two and
three
council auburn mentioned those
specifically and i think it's prudent
given the fact that plot one isn't
significantly changing at all from the
previous approval and also their
proximity to each other
uh would appear cramped and congested in
the street scene
and results against significant harm to
the character appearance of the area
and obviously not outweigh by the public
benefits because obviously that is
something that i know members consider
in terms of the benefit of providing
these houses
um but also with particular regard as
well to the extent
permission um but that that would be
contrary to
qd02 which is the uh policy the local
pound which deals with
the um impact on character appearance of
the
of the mppf uh sorry of the uh of the
local plan
um so that's that's the motion so be a
um i think a refusal on the grounds of
uh by virtue of the density and scale of
plots two and three
um and their proximity to each other
would result in a cramped and congested
uh form of development um resulting in
significant harm to the current
appearance of the area contrary to qd02
thank you jeff uh thank you ian uh as
usual i need
if uh members are happy of what mr
livingston has
stated there um the reasons for you uh
could i have a proposal for please
i'll be happy with those on
who was first council blackfoot i think
was first year
oh thank you and a second please
well second then thank you thank you
council ghana well once again
um i will have to go through your names
uh
if you're happy with that proposal from
mr liverson we have a proposal and
secondary
uh council coleman cook
um for councillor alban
for councillor bayford
sorry um four four
oh yes for this to be sorry four yes
okay myself else beg your pardon
okay thank you
thank you yes i come back to you
councillor bay for jaw or
yes thank you also councillor curry
4 accountant duckworth
12 council ghana four
councillor heart forger councillor keane
four councilloratican four
councillor scott porter councillor
taylor
four counts of right for
and i am for as well so that
has been carried unanimously
um so um
i'm just getting confirmation like i
like to um
[Music]
yeah yes thank you very much katie
right members that does conclude our
meeting today
um i don't think i've missed anything
out i'm sure i'll be told if i have
um our next meeting is
two weeks time which is on the second
of december wednesday the second at the
same time
um again just into our news and look at
the rest of it please please stay
safe careful um
are you washing your hands counselor
alban i'm washing my hands of this
committee chair at the moment
thank you thank you members and thank
you officers
um and uh i don't think we've
beaten world record on that one but
again very interesting
thank you members thank you